hey guys I'm Callie I'm John Luke and
Call of Duty World War 2 has officially
been revealed officially this this is a
world war 2 game about the European
theater so no Pacific Theater taking
place basically between 44 and 45 maybe
some leeway there but we went to
sledgehammer the developer a little
while ago to get a behind-the-scenes
look and we got to see two scenes that
you guys haven't seen yet yes yeah we
also found out and this is a cool thing
that we didn't actually get to see in
action but that you while you're
primarily following an American squad um
you'll be able to play a female French
resistance fighter
yeah sounded pretty cool they described
it as sort of like basically their
version of all Gilly DUP where it's
gonna be sort of stealth based yeah
killing Nazis yeah it sounded really rad
but unfortunately we didn't get to see
anything about that yeah but also that's
cool that they're actually like
incorporating female characters yeah I
mean the game I didn't expect that for a
World War 2 game um and so you know call
GD has touched on the liberation of
France before but um I excited to see
what they do with this character um but
what we did see the first scene mission
that we saw was working for us um Hurk
insaneness for the Battle of her kin
forest is famous for the Nazis would
blow the tops of the trees off and
create like all this shrapnel that would
uh like rain down rain down on everyone
um yeah so a lot of separate like
skirmishes happened in her Ken but the
one we see is you're playing this
nineteen year old American first
Infantry Division like fighting for just
a like drafty basically um and you're
kind of like you're going through this
forest you can hear the like sound of
him like sloshing through the river and
uh you can hear his breathing he sounds
scared and nervous and it's so cool how
like just his breathing I would like
already was like okay totally get the
tone and then it everything hits the fan
yeah so there's a little bit of sniper
scene kind of like running through the
woods shooting uh there it is typical
call duty gunplay but it looks really
good it looks good you see I mean like
there's a whole lot of Germans in that
forest yes
um kind of getting back to the basics
where a lot of like focus on you have
your squad with you right and just like
a lot of overwhelming enemies kind of it
I've been recently playing some of the
older colleges and definitely feels more
like that yeah they talked about taking
call to be back to its roots that's sort
of their mo here
sledgehammer that is um yeah and then
the bombing start yeah just like this
it's this really cool sequencer you're
just like running through as all of the
like trees are exploding it looks great
it's like a classic kind of like Call of
Duty like set-piece moment but yeah it's
absolutely good yes absolutely one of
those like exciting World War two
moments um
but I liked that it was tempered by the
beginning part of the mission that we
saw where it's it's a little slower yeah
um we we talked to a bunch of different
departments but the one of the coolest
things about the forest sequence the
bombing sequence in that forest is the
audio director yeah told us that the
team all because they're sledgehammer
games always brings a sledgehammer with
them when they go out to record like
Foley's and different sound effects and
he showed us like them just like
smashing these twigs and these trees in
a forest jammer with a sledgehammer to
get the ax to get those sound effects
and then they magnify it to the point
where it's like reverberating in your
chest and it's such a cool sequence yeah
it was really rad and then the other
secrets we gotta see was the actual like
landing on the beaches of Normandy
dorming in Normandy um yeah it's not
anything special in the sense that like
if you've seen a Normandy invasion scene
you know see if you've seen one you've
seen them all sort of I think the reason
that it wasn't like earth-shattering for
me is because we don't know these
characters yet and this is a
character-driven story which i think is
what you have to do right to separate
this Normandy from all the other
Normandy seems to be the approach
they're taking with this game in general
and since they're focusing on the
squad's like even if you're seeing
familiar sequences like a storming of
Normandy yeah the characters will like
give it a new like feel like a regional
field yeah and at the beginning we kind
of do get that where um you know you're
in the boats and there's a lot of like
up close shots with your squad mates
like
as the boats are getting attacked you
see Josh Jamal who's like your squad
leader he's in the Soyuz game from the
Transformers movies uh his animation
looked really good I was really
impressed with the Kevin Spacey stuff
they did in advanced warfare oh yeah and
so slub sledgehammers previous game was
advanced warfare and there's a little
work little work on modern warfare 3 but
yet Kevin Spacey like looked like Kevin
Spacey advanced warfare uh and this is
like that ramped up like a fine-tuned
tools it looked really good the scene
itself was once you like landed on the
beaches it was like really cool because
you're basically given this one of those
devices they would use where they would
on like stick it into the sand to like
blow up like the barricade they had it
so you could get through and so you
don't have a gun and you just have to
run all the way to the other side of the
beach and like you've seen a bunch of
people die around you the water is red
like yeah it's horrific and it's running
from cover to cover it's really intense
the gore doesn't feel gratuitous either
like I really felt like they were trying
to to show that this was not this this
is unlike the Hurtgen sequence this is
not like cool and exciting it's Terry
yeah it's dead like and you're see up
close like some like this guy's face is
like blown in and it's not super graphic
like it's not like he's missing his face
but I don't feel like they're trying to
glorify it the way for example I thought
world at war maybe like went a little
too far right in it it does feel very
like Saving Private Ryan and they talked
to that about that being an inspiration
but the coolest thing about when you are
putting that whatever that device is
yeah the name escapes me but to blow up
the barricades you fumble you fumble it
and like you're like somebody who's with
you is like no you can do it you're
almost there yeah this is cool I imagine
will be like a sense of as you played
the game your character maybe gets more
confident yeah and stuff like that the
other scene they show they kind of like
skip ahead and they show the actual like
you running through kind of like the
trenches and and dealing with the
bunkers getting into the bunkers and
they against typical call duty gunplay
all the weapons you can expect nothing
new its World War two
you see all the weapons in world war ii
yeah they did
invent any new weapons exactly they did
go out and shoot all these weapons to
rerecord all the sounds that just sounds
like the coolest job there is like a
QuickTime event that I wasn't super
stoked yeah because I'm not generally
stoked on me me me too it's kind of
whatever one little cool animation they
showed was at one point you can actually
do like a dive on to the ground to avoid
enemy fire which is a cool mechanic that
they haven't had in previous Call of
Duty games but also added to sort of
like that feeling of like being someone
who's like has no idea what they're
doing and like just doesn't want to die
a ninety-year-old who had a week of
basic and was sent off to war you know
that was pretty cool and that's the
coolest thing about the Normandy
sequences we see a lot of the animation
in action we talked to the animation
director when we were there um and
basically they had to reteach a lot of
their mocap guys are like actually
trained with for combat and they had to
be like no forget everything you thought
you knew these guys in this game did not
know any of those things and that's not
how they fought they tried to minimize
the amount of target and they would turn
to the side and like that's not how you
fight anymore and they just did so much
research and I was so impressed because
I got that sense watching the sequence
like you fumble and you you're
staggering and you're running and it's
it's not clean
you're not overpowered and I really
really liked that yeah they're different
going back to that more like you're not
a super soldier feel with this dude just
a dude and I really liked that about it
so that was it for the single-player we
did get to they talked about multiplayer
but we didn't actually get to see any
didn't see anything but they're gonna do
a full reveal that at e3 they said yeah
it'll be playable in the show floor and
since e3 is open to the public that
means fans and anybody curious go check
it out which is cool um but I think the
thing that stuck out to me the most from
what they said about multiplayer was
that it was gonna be more narrative like
access versus allies battles instead of
just kind of like an all-out thing I
don't think they would ever get rid of
TDM like I no no this was specifically a
mode called war yeah that was going to
be like a narrative driven kind of makes
me think of domination from last year's
battlefield 1 yeah kind of had that same
thing where they would intercut it with
like text or not text a voiceover we I
talked about like the actual historical
battles and we we at this point well you
can only speculate that's kind of what
it seemed like they were going for and
then the other thing was that there
would be destiny like like at the tower
yeah kind of social spaces that's weird
and I'm just now realizing like
Activision own destiny so like that
maybe kind of makes sense in trailer
trying to like incorporate elements of
that but yeah like the idea that you
have this um sort of like camp like you
know where you can hang out with like
was at forty people uh yeah I think they
said something around that and it was
it's gonna be like oh you can chat with
people you can customize stuff it seems
like y'all ready you'll be able to like
create a character it sounded like
because they were saying they wanted it
to feel like you're in least like a
you've enlisted like totally yeah so
that kind of sounds like you have like a
character sort of that you yeah sort of
like character that you build up um much
interesting interesting idea don't know
curious how I feel like Call of Duty
players just kind of want to play Call
of Duty and maybe aren't as interested
in that social space if indeed I see
yeah for sure I mean maybe this is
something that's for players who are
interested in world war two more so than
they are called gee yes um and then the
last thing was they were like coops a
thing yep but we didn't see any of that
so yeah they said uh like there will be
a new enemy uh but that was about it
what does that mean doesn't sound like
zombies they kind of I think it's
something else
uh uh but in my hopes for Pacific
Theater were pretty pretty - um no for
this one
so it was like just European front but I
do want to stress like everybody we
talked to you every department we went
to um was everyone was like yeah the
first thing we did was just we just read
about World War two and we watch
documentaries and they looked at gun
manuals like the field manuals that
soldiers got and like they just totally
immerse themselves in the history and
that was the coolest part of this studio
visit for me yeah a big thing for me
about like because their whole tagline
is that they're going back to their
roots and they've been saying uh there's
like the setting right over old war -
like you said that's the obvious going
back to your roots but I feel like
there's more to it than that like
there's there's the tonal approach and
like how they handle World War two that
I think like when you just look at the
way ecology is kind of
more lately garages and it feels a
little more like bombastic and a little
dubrow ish in kind of their approach to
ingre yeah exactly and uh crawl dude he
was always a little bit more respectful
than that the originals and I was kind
of worried like okay you actually going
to handle this appropriately and from
what they've shown and what they've
talked about absolutely yeah I think
they're on the right path yeah
absolutely we talked to animation audio
narrative studio heads and art those
departments and everybody was like yeah
we we want to show respect for not only
the people who fought in this war but
people who were affected by this war and
from what we've seen it seems like
they're striking a good balance between
like those exciting set pieces like in
Huracan and something a little more with
a little more depth and and you know
getting better facial animation
technology and getting that range of
emotion as part of that the acting is
part of that making sure it's true to
what the experience of being a soldier
in World War two was like and all of
that was doing their homework and so um
that's what makes me most interested in
this game for sure hundred percent and
then I'm also just like really clear to
see like just game play like I'm kind of
it's kind of nice to go back to that
more like simplistic yeah feel
especially like I'm really curious how
the multiplayer is going to play out you
know like you're not yeah I can't wall
run anymore you can't double jump yeah
like what does that mean for eSports
these are all questions I still have
yeah and really curious about that yeah
I think we had a really good impression
mmm and I just I just want to see more
if you want to see more we have news and
features up on GameSpot right now that
you can check out and the trailer is out
and all of that so be sure to look at
those things if you're curious let us
know ething in the comments and thank
you for watching bye
[Music]